and I'm gonna tell you something that a
lot of people 99% of people disagree
with me on it wasn't as though in
creating these companies that we thought
that we would be successful I thought
that the most likely outcome was failure
I want to know going back 50 years what
it was like when you first met Warren
well I thought he was a prodigy and I
got a lot of criticism wanna be happy
build a life not just a business
[Music]
hates Evan Carmichael and this channel
was created to help you overcome the
number one challenge that is holding you
back a lack of belief in yourself you
watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you -
you've got Michael Jordan level talent
at something so today let's live your
best believed life and learn seven of
the best lessons from billionaire
entrepreneurs
okay let's kick it off with lesson
number one don't fear failure with Elon
Musk we got to try to create an electric
car company but it wasn't as though in
creating these companies that we thought
that we would be successful I thought
that the most likely outcome was failure
but but it was still worth doing even
though the odds of success were low in
fact in full force for SpaceX the
originally what I started doing was not
creating a rocket company but but
actually was gonna do a small mission to
Mars which was just a philanthropic
mission where we would send a small
green house with seeds and dehydrator
gel in the gourd upon landing hydrate
the gel and you'd have this cool picture
of green plants on a red background and
the public tends to respond to
precedents and superlatives so this we
the first life on Mars where this the
life's ever traveled and you'd have this
great money shot of green plants on the
right background and so I thought that
would get people's attention so but but
the expectation for that was was no
return so they expect I thought we
wouldn't get any you know we'll just
spend the money on that and it wouldn't
wouldn't happen lesson number two find
amazing partners with Warren Buffett
Warren is probably the most rational
person I've ever met
Charlie Munger would be a close rival
and Charlie became a man that Warren
depended on heavily and I think his
first experiences in the discarded cigar
butt era convinced him that it was not
exactly where he wanted to be he made so
much money for so long doing what he'd
been taught by Ben Graham which there by
these very cheap stocks if they were
cheap enough he didn't care it was a
lousy company in a lousy
management he knew he was gonna make
money anyway just because of the
cheapness Charlie Munger's had a big
impact on me in moving me toward looking
for wonderful companies at fair prices
rather than fair companies at wonderful
prices that was enormous ly important
because it enabled Berkshire to scale up
in a way that would have been impossible
to do otherwise we were metal partners
right from the moment we met
I want to know going back 50 years what
it was like when you first met Warren
well I thought he was a prodigy and I
got a lot of criticism my wife said why
are you paying such enormous respect of
a young man with a crew-cut who won't
eat vegetables ungodly smart he's got a
much broader intellect an idea and he's
magnificent at being able to condense
important ideas and the just a very few
words if you're not interested in the
economic scene right now
you're mentally dead Charlie has no tact
all right let's talk a little bit about
bankers Charlie on Friday compared them
to heroin addicts
yeah well that's colorful Charlie but I
would not have chosen that I once wrote
of him that when they handed out
humility he didn't get his fair share
the ideal way to run a headquarters is
to have one man preferably over 80
sitting in an office by himself
anything else is pure for every he's
always honest then what he tells me so I
listen to him
we never had an argument we just
we just gotta roll with it easily
suppose Warren doesn't want to do
something that I would have done and
suppose that happens four times over
four years
what the hell difference would it make
to me net the record is working out fun
lesson number three
follow your dreams with Jack Ma in my
apartment where we started eighteen
founders and we aim high we have a dream
we say we want to make become the top
ten Internet companies or websites in
the world guys at that time we are
ranking several meaning name who is it
won't be double Ted the top ten of the
world we want to make this company last
a hundred two years and we don't know
where's our pay next month Wow
when you are poor if you have a dreams
you never feel poor you know what we are
doing so after we never say we will be
we will win next year or we win tomorrow
we say we will weigh in 10 20 years 19
years past today we are the top 10
websites coming to the competition the
world also if you want to have more
confidence and self-love check out my
254 series they're free the links to
join on the description below the people
who did the bottom should believe in the
model and I believe what I do become so
skilled so vigilant so flat-out
fantastic at what you do that your
talent cannot be dismissed
I always did everything back ass half
words you know I like to challenge
myself lesson number four act on your
ideas with Jeff Bezos I came across the
fact so this is 1994 nobody has heard of
the internet very very few people and I
came across the fact that the web World
Wide Web was growing at something like
23 hundred percent a year this is a 1984
and anything growing that fast is even
if it's baseline usage today is tiny
it's growing so fast it's gonna be big
and so I looked at that and I was like
there's got to be I should come up with
a business idea
then you know on the internet and then
let the internet go around this and we
can keep working on it and so I made a
list of products that I might saw online
and I started forced ranking them and I
picked books because books is super
unusual in one respect which is that
there are more book items in the book
category than there are items in any
other category the three million
different books active and in print
around the world in a given time so my
my the founding idea of Amazon was to
build Universal selection of books the
biggest bookstores only had 150,000
titles and so that's what I did and I
you know I hired a small team and we
built we built the software I moved to
Seattle and when you told your parents
you're gonna quit de sha where you're
successful making presumably a fair
amount of money yeah and you told your
wife McKenzie that you're gonna move
across the country what did they all say
they were immediately and reflexively
supportive right after they asked the
question what's the internet lesson
number five use humor to your advantage
with Sara Blakely I know that as part of
the Spanx training bootcamp one of the
mandatory learning modules is comedy
that every employee has to go through so
why is that important I want it I didn't
understand why why everybody was so
serious so I thought you know what I
don't subscribe to the fact that you
have to act serious to be taken
seriously and I like to laugh at myself
I you know I looked when I worked in
corporate America for a long time and
everybody was super uptight and super
serious and there was no humor and there
was no levity and then everybody at like
5:00 o'clock became ragingly hilarious
like what what's going on like you know
and so the alcohol probably helped you
know but but anyway I I wanted to to use
humor and I love to do that in the
workplace and yes we have a boot camp at
Spanx a training boot camp when you come
on board and one of the modules is doing
stand-up comedy and I've used the
comedic stuff that I did in my marketing
I mean I wrote don't worry we've got
your butt covered right on my package
when I first started in 2000 which was
not very common to do especially taking
it to the Neiman Marcus to sell it I
named my company Spanx which was you
know made people laugh and believe it or
not it was very shocking at the time
that I name
the company spanks actually had people
hang up on me often I would call them
and say hi I'm Sara from Spanx and then
they'd hang up and I'd call back and I
go I'm serious I'm a real company and my
company's called spinning and they go oh
oh I thought you were prank calling me
so and then you know naming my products
I broke into the world's most boring
category I mean can we talk about
shapewear who wants to talk about
shapewear and undergarments but it was I
named it power panties you know I
started naming all my products and it
made people laugh and it gave so much
energy and then all of a sudden you had
Gwyneth Paltrow and Julia Roberts
flashing their Spanx on red carpets and
saying I'm wearing Spanx like all these
celebrities and I think it's because I
chose to do humor and people wanted to
participate in that there was energy
around that so so I use it in every
aspect of the marketing I use humor to
turn around a situation when I'm bombing
it it might give me a second chance
when I cold called to sell fax machines
door-to-door for seven years I learned
very quickly that if I could make
somebody laugh or smile I'd get another
30 seconds before they'd slam the door
in my face there's just it's helps you
move through pain it's it's it's a
wonderful tool rule number six follow
your effort with Mark Cuban and I'm
gonna tell you something that a lot of
people 99 percent of people disagree
with me on right everybody says follow
your passions I say that's [ __ ]
right I say follow your efforts it's
amazing how we're all passionate about
things we are all passionate about
something helping veterans helping this
organization helping this group that's
great but it no matter what at all Nets
out to where do you put your time
because when people put in their time
you get better at things and when you
get better at something and get good at
something then you have a chance to be
great at something and you know what
I've learned
nobody ever quits anything they're great
at and once you get great at it's
amazing how passionate you become about
it follow your efforts right because
it's not in the Dreaming it's in the
doing and lesson number seven the last
one before a very special bonus clip is
build trust with Oprah Winfrey I think
in order to actually
do the stuff yes money is important but
I also think the thing that I hold the
dearest and the reason why the noise
about running for president moved me so
humbly and deeply is because it means
that you have somewhere in the work
gained the people's trust yes you and
there is nothing more important to me
than having the trust of the people and
the audience and I I mean I recognize
that it is the audience who came every
day and watched you know from all over
the world that actions yes that helped
me to be Who I am so I think the
renowned that the standing the the
ability to be trusted and to say
something but also much listen don't
play the billionaire things small don't
play the be small yeah it's it's it's a
very big deal because it allows you to
it allows you to actually do the work so
instead of saying gee I would like to
help so many people or you should go out
and help so many people you can actually
use that for yourself and I am now at
this stage of my career thinking about
how to do that more poignant Lee and
fruitfully I'm now looking for ways that
I can do that to create a level of
sustainability in within our communities
that will go long beyond my lifetime now
have a special bonus clip from John Paul
DeJoria on how to be prepared for
rejections that I think you're going to
enjoy but before that it's time for the
three point landing questions let's go
from just watching the video to taking
an action here we go question number one
what fear of failure do you have that
you need to let go of number two what
idea do you have that you need to
immediately act on and number three
where do you need to follow your effort
and if you like this video and promise
you take action after watching it give
me a hash tag believe down in the
comments as well we don't just watch
videos here we do something about it so
give me a
I believe make that promise to yourself
and then get to work the best advice I
can give is number one be prepared for a
lot of rejection if you're ready for
rejection of people say no I don't want
it no it's not going to work no this is
crazy whatever if you're prepared for it
it's not going to let you down
learn from your failures I had a lot of
failures along the way even with my
patron and Paul Mitchell but we learn
from those things then we get a lot
better
if you want to know more lessons from
billionaire entrepreneurs check out the
video right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there
the starting company our advice and
people to have a high pain tolerance
remember if you want to be successful
learn from the other people's mistakes